Brady thought that 10 was a really boring element,
but we've changed his mind showing him that it does more than it says on the
tin.
What we can show you is how 10 melts,
how you can join wires on the battlefield while you're being
fired at, by the enemy.
How you can stop things growing on the bottom of sips.
And also give you a few hints about a first-year chemistry course.
If you've come here to the university,
10 is in group 14, the same group has carbon.
So it is below germanium and above led.
It was really valuable in prehistoric times because
it was found that when you mix it with copper,
you could make bronze and bronze melts at a lower
temperature than copper. So it's easier to make weapons.
And the weapons were harder.
10 is found in a variety of minerals.
There are lots of sources of it in China, in Malaysia,
and also in Cornwall in the West of England.
After the oil has been crushed and washed,
the tin oxide is dried and the sample is tested for quality and good design
project year with 140 pounds of 10 come a ton of all.
Still many abandoned tin mines in Cornwall.
They're quite dangerous. When you walk across the malls, there are open shafts,
which if you're not looking where you're going, you can fall down.
Cornell could provide a third of all the tin required by this country.
We have been trying to look at 10 beginning with the metal.
One of the interesting things about tin is that it melts at quite a low
temperature. So if you heat it up,
it melts around 230 degrees centigrade.
So even with a gas torch, you can melt it quite easily in the glass test tube.
[Inaudible].
This low melting point is very useful for a whole series of
applications, particularly for so-called soda.
That is joining things, electrically. This is soda.
It is the metal,
which is used to make electrical connections in this case on a
very old computer memory board now to make joints like
this requires precise tools, and it's a bit boring,
but what we want to show you is how people joined wires together on the
battlefield. For example, in the second world war,
you've got to imagine you're on the battlefield. People are shooting at you.
You need to put down the telephone wires.
So you can talk to the groups on either side of you.
And the last thing you want to do is to get out to soldiering, I, and,
and wait for it to heat up. And so on.
I remembered that I had some self soldiering joints,
which I got when I was an army cadet. When I was about 15,
that's a copper tube with some soldier inside and some material
that burns so that you can light it like a match.
So you take the two bits of electrical wire.
You want to join post one piece of wire in each end,
and then you light it. The soldier is insight.
I've had these 56 years and they weren't new when they got them.
So they probably come from the second world war. They'd probably surplus.
I thought they would work. Neil was a bit dubious as usual.
I was right.
So Neil set fire to the red part,
which is some sort of igniting mixture and it flared up
quite quickly. And then you can see the whole tube gets very hot. Now,
of course you can't see the soldier because that's inside, but as it gets hot,
the soldier melts and runs around the
wires. And then as it cools down, it solidifies,
fixing the wires into the soap piece of copper tube.
On one occasion, we did it more than once.
You could see the soda coming out, just on one side.
[Inaudible].
Just to show that the soldier was in there.
I persuaded Neil and our new assistant Connor.
Who's joining our team to heat one of these pieces
vertically so that when the soldier melts,
it will drop out to the bottom.
[Inaudible].
Just to show you the guilt hops. We put the thermocouple,
which niches temperature into the top.
So you can see the temperature going up and you can see the soldier running out.
[Inaudible].
So we were really quite excited.
Then we thought 10 is in the same group has carbon carbon burns.
So perhaps 10 will burn well in the Bunsen, we found some very nice,
finally pouted 10 Neil started sprinkling the tin
into the flame of the Bunsen burner. And it was really beautiful.
You could see all.
Sorts of swirling flames.
And when the tin went into the flame, you got quite a bright colored light.
Now there's some argument whether it was valid or look,
and, but there was a touch of green as well,
which I think came off his bachelor.
It was really much more beautiful than any of us expected.
And then Neil had a really good idea.
He fed the powder into the air hole of the Bunsen
burner.
The stream of gas then blew the powder up into the
flame and that looked even better.
So we had two really good experiments demonstrations.
And so we felt really ready to go for a third. Now,
tin is very well known of having two different forms of the
metal.
One of them is shiny and looks just like any other metal.
The other one is meant to be a sort of brownish color and crumbles away.
This transition between the two happens at low temperature.
And I'd seen the terrific time-lapse video on YouTube,
where you can see a block of metallic tin,
gradually crumbling away as this so-called tin pest spreads
across. So we thought we will try the same,
but perhaps we were not quite so patient.
So first of all,
I had the tin soldier and we tried dunking the soldier
in liquid nitrogen.
It came out looking much the same,
but we hoped it's transformed inside.
So Neil thumped it with a hammer
that was successful. It shattered the bits,
but there was absolutely no evidence that the metals had changed.
It was just Neil's power that smashed it.
So we then tried a different experiment,
melting the tin and pouring the molten tin,
the liquid tin into liquid nitrogen.
The thinking here was that if we froze the liquid quickly,
it would go into the unstable form directly without going through the
metallic one. So it was really quite spectacular when it went in,
there were great plumes of vapor, vapor,
water vapor as nitrogen evaporated. And when we took it out,
it was a relevant,
beautiful shape of long piece of tin,
But it was the shape of the test tube. So it looked by the autistic,
but it didn't demonstrate what we wanted.
We thought perhaps we were being a bit impatient.
So we left it in liquid nitrogen overnight while the piece of
string in case it crumbled away. And sadly,
when we took it out the next day still hadn't transformed.
We've been completely unsuccessful.
I think that when we did, we've done it to lower temperature.
You probably need it a bit below freezing point of water.
So minus 10, minus 20 degrees centigrade.
And when it's really cold liquid nitrogen temperature,
the atoms don't have enough thermal energy to rearrange.
If we left it in liquid nitrogen for a couple of years,
perhaps something would happen. So as well as bronze,
there's a very well known alloy of tin called pewter.
Originally it was tin and lead.
It's now tin with other metals is particularly famous in Malaysia,
you get many souvenirs. And when I was in Malaysia,
I was given this plate made that pewter.
And the reason why people like it is because you can melt it quite
easily and make it into elaborate shapes. Like the pattern on this plate.
Now we really haven't talked about the chemistry. Yet.
10 is in the same group has carbon.
So it has four electrons in the outer shell.
But unlike carbon,
it can either use two of these electrons or four of these electrons for
bonding. When it uses two electrons,
it forms say 10 dichloride standers chloride,
which is a salt rather like sodium chloride.
So it dissolves in water makes a slightly cloudy
mixture if you put too much in, but it dissolves,
but it will not dissolve in organic solvents. Like cyclohexane.
On the other hand, if you use four electrons,
you can make compounds like tin Tetra iodide,
which is one of the compounds our students make in the first year lab.
And we had two samples made by students and you can see the colors are a bit
different because one made the purest sample than the other.
The 10 Tetra iodide is like an organic compound.
If you put this one in water,
the tin ID in bones react with,
so you get hydrogen iodide, which you can't see,
and you get to precipitate of tin oxide, which is white.
If you put it in an organic solvent, it dissolves.
So you get a nice yellow solution. I wouldn't say anymore.
Or you might cheat when you're a student here,
10 oxides are important in screens on smart
phones and similar things because this display
consists of a material,
which is sandwiched between two electrodes.
And obviously the electrode through which you're looking has to be transparent
and indium tin oxide.
That's a mixed oxide,
indium and tin is electrically conducting,
but is transparent.
So Indian tin oxide is a key component of most
smartphones and other displays. So if you're watching this,
you're probably watching it through thin film of indium tin oxide.
The final application of 10,
I want to tell you about involves ships. This is a wooden ship,
but it's the only one I could find when the ship is made.
Obviously the bottom of the ship is absolutely clean,
but as it sails around the seas, various Marine organisms,
mussels, barnacles, and so on,
fix themselves to the bottom of the sheep and start growing.
So eventually the bottom of the ship looks around the Lake,
my hair with covered in these Marine organisms.
And this greatly slows down the shape.
It doesn't go through the water so easily. So for centuries,
people have tried different sorts of coating on the bottom of ships for
so-called antifouling to stop organisms growing on them,
a very successful method is involved using organic tin compounds,
usually derivatives of tribute, titled tin.
These are very effective in preventing growth on the bottom of ship.
The problem is that the tin can leech dissolve
off the bottom of the sheep and particularly Nieuports because there are a
lot of ships there and they spend quite a lot of time there.
And when the tin comes out,
of course it stops the organisms,
the barnacles fixing onto rocks and all sorts of things.
So in recent years,
there's been quite a strong movement to stop using tin in antifouling paints
and to use clever paint chemistry to make the bottom so smooth,
but nothing can stick to it.
There you go. And to think, I thought a video about 10 would be boring.
As you probably know,
we've made videos about all the elements on the periodic table,
but like the one you just watched, then we're redoing them,
making them bigger and better. If you'd like to support us,
help us make new videos,
like the people whose names you see on the screen at the moment you can back us
on Patrion, go to patrion.com/periodic videos,
Patrion supporters, occasionally get little extra goodies. For example,
I'm about to share with them this video about the professor's Ty collection.
You haven't lived until you've seen a video about the professors tie collection.
Anyway, there are links down in the video description.
Thank you so much for watching and we'll be back soon.